mein thema kommt heute aus der show aber
auch nicht ganz es ist johnny depp hat
gegen alba haut vor gericht gewonnen ein
us gericht hat die missbrauchs vorwürfe
von amber heard gegenüber johnny depp
abgeschmettert es ist ein wichtiges
urteil eines zeigt ja auch frauen können
täter sein können männer verleumden
ihren ruf in den dreck ziehen und sind
dem meeting vernichten in den letzten
jahren seit dem aufkommen der mito
bewegung im jahr 2016 wurden männer
vermehrt öffentlich hingerichtet viele
zu recht schweine wie habe 110 oder auch
jeffrey epstein verurteilt von gerichten
doch es gibt auch fälle den aussage
gegen aussage steht und die beweislage
mehr als dünn ist der comedian luke
mockridge ist so ein fall bei ihm seine
ex-freundin es an juni wegen versuchter
vergewaltigung
angezeigt hatte folgte eine
gesellschaftliche hinrichtung dabei
wurde das verfahren gegen ihn
eingestellt
ich möchte heute mit der runde darüber
debattieren ja wie es eigentlich ist ob
nicht mehr länger in deutschland die
unschuldsvermutung gilt und was man
eigentlich dagegen tun kann wenn jemand
von der gesellschaft vorverurteilt wird
mein fazit ist mentor dieses urteil war
ein wichtiger schritt für die
gleichberechtigung
ja also sie sprechen dann glaube ich
ganz wichtige dinge an allerdings würde
ich diesen fall gar nicht so sehr als
sozusagen für eine seite sehen sondern
in den situationen ist es immer so dass
es menschliches schicksal ist und es
steht ganz als er fast immer aussage
gegen aussage
und da ist es natürlich ganz wichtig
unvoreingenommen dem gegenüber zu stehen
und das ist gerade wenn es um
sexualdelikt oder häusliche gewalt geht
häufig nicht der fall so dass wir
durchaus eine vorverurteilende
presseberichterstattung zum einen haben
aber zum anderen jetzt nur weil diese
entscheidung so gefallen ist heißt das
auch noch nicht dass die entscheidung
richtig war deswegen ich sehe das auch
bei twitter dass es teilweise gefeiert
wird ja hier sieg auf der richtigen
seite wir wissen uns einfach nicht also
wir kennen den prozess leider besser als
wir ihn kennen sollte das muss man dazu
sagen ich denke dieses thema ist
allerdings nicht nur ein juristisches
thema nämlich dass es eben auf falsche
beschuldigungen gibt es schadet den die
tatsächlich opfer von gewalt werden er
schadet aber auch schreckt natürlich
dann ab denn opfer von gewalt überlegen
sich dreimal ob sie jetzt hier diesen
ganzen prozess durchmachen was als
strafverteidigerin sehr gut ich würde
auch manchmal die nebenklage und es kann
natürlich sein im zweifel für den
angeklagten das auch jemand der
tatsächlich schuldig war freigesprochen
wird das heißt aber noch lange nicht
dass die beschuldigung nicht gestimmt
hat denn natürlich sind die
anforderungen auch sehr hoch was ich
aber viel problematischer finde ist dass
dieser prozess ich meine haben sich zwei
menschen die wollten sich vernichten
also anders kann man es nicht mehr sagen
eine solche plattform bekommen haben ein
solches interesse von der gesamten
weltbevölkerung schon fast dass ich
sagen muss so kann rechtsstaat nicht
funktionieren und man sollte auch als
journalist journalistin in solchen
stellen eher ein bisschen zurückhaltung
üben um soeben rechtsstaatlichen prozess
auch nicht zu gefährden am ende das
würde es bei uns auch so nicht geben da
sehr amerikanisch diese totale
veröffentlichung öffentlichmachung
dieser ganzen vorgänge im deutschen
strafgerichten würde man da schon sehr
aufpassen dass das ein bisschen
diskreter gemacht werde ich bin ich will
nur dass alle zusagen dazu noch oder 1
punkt sagen es ist eigentlich mit das
heikelste thema sexualdelikte
vergewaltigung weil du fast immer nicht
ganz sicher wisst wem du eigentlich
glauben kannst ich hab das ja selbst mal
erlebt als fahren da war ja auch mal
oder bin ja eigentlich gelernter jurist
aber sie hat sich jahrzehnte hier in
einer strafkammer bei solchen prozessen
ist extrem schwer herausfinden wer
schwindelt sich jetzt an und wer sagt
die wahrheit
das geht es gibt leichtere sachen zu
beurteilen und als strafrichter
ist eine französische schriftstellerin
eine sehr gute zeitgenössische
schriftstellerin und die hat gerade
einen großartigen roman gehabt hauser
herausgebracht die heiße show wenn
menschliche dinge und da ist genau das
der sachverhalt es gibt eine
vorverurteilung twitter und so weiter
dass er der täter ist also der junge aus
gutem französischen elternhaus für
gewaltig die orthodoxe jüdin ja das ist
so der plot und am ende kommt zum
gerichtsverfahren um das gericht stellt
fest dass das was sozusagen juristisch
der aktuar keine vergewaltigung ist und
dass die sozusagen twitter und so
vorverurteilt haben das wirklich den
berichten guter roman und ich hoffe dass
der übersetzte juristische teil
funktioniert er wahrscheinlich bei uns
auch noch ganz gut aber es gibt immer
zwei seiten die probleme müssten die
eine ist es gibt eine art von vorwürfen
die sie buchstäblich ruinieren ja
milliarden sehen wenn sie öffentlich
personen sind egal ob sie stimmen oder
nicht dazu gehören solche sachen wie
kinderpornografie oder so was wir jetzt
anders versichert und zweitens gilt aber
halt leider auch weil ich so schwer ist
zu beweisen es gab bei vielen frauen so
dass sie sich schon überhaupt anzeige zu
erstatten sie werden teilweise sogar
abgehalten und ich haben in der jungen
richter gelesen hat oder der würde sagen
das nicht empfehlen da anzeige zu
erstatten weil am ende werden wir das
alles durchgeknetet halböffentlich und
es kommt nichts dabei heraus es
wahnsinnig schwer ist es nachzuweisen
und davon gibt es die beiden seiten da
gibt es diejenigen die gewalt allein das
wird nicht bestraft das sind schlecht
dran und die die falsch beschuldigt
werden immer sicher weniger aber kommt
teil auch vor wenn davor auf
entsprechende öffentliche personen da
sind sie erledigt aldi hat gibt unfälle
kachelmann zum beispiel türk zum
beispiel die waren danach ja wirklich
ich stehe jetzt bestimmt nicht glaube
ich dass man denkt er herr kachelmann
und ich werden freunde wenn man sich
unsere twitter profile anschaut aber mit
rückblicken leid was mit dem mann
passiert ist und ich frage mich schon ob
so ein prozess überhaupt hilft dass die
gesellschaft so stark vorverurteilen
also im fall von luke mockridge das war
damals beim comedypreis das war
furchtbar für mich anzusehen obwohl ich
den manchmal scanner wie er dort
verurteilt wurde ohne dass überhaupt
schon was vor gericht vorstand und es
war da ja schon eigentlich noch aussage
gegen aussage und da frage ich mich
schon mit zwei juristen ja auch ob man
gar nicht was dagegen tun kann dann sind
wir doch an einem ganz wunden punkt
nämlich an eigentlich einer angebrachten
selbst kritik der medien die
vorverurteilung finden doch fast immer
in den medien statt weil natürlich muss
man so einen fall aufgreifen und dann
spitzt man die fälle auch zu da hat das
gericht überhaupt noch gar kein ton
gesagt und trotzdem kommt er der mann
oder die frau wenn du ihn das sehr
geschickt läuft dann gemacht wird kommt
aus diesem ding nie mehr raus die kann
auch freigesprochen werden es ist völlig
wurscht ist bleibt was hängen das ist ja
auch die methode irgendwas bleibt schon
hängen das macht man ja auch wenn man
skandale hoch blinken hoch bringt in der
politik ohne dass man
das wirklich ganz hart belegen kann aber
erst mal los
in einer eher in einer sache beschuldigt
wird dann sagen sie den kenne ich gar
nicht also das dann also dass sich
absetzungen jemand der unter druck das
sind personen jahren haft ich habe
eigentlich gegenteilig ein impuls für
die tech ist ein anständiger mensch und
man wird zunehmen falls man nicht einen
schlechten charakter und ich bin mit dem
gar nicht gesehen wenn wir was dabei
rauskommt das ist so ein stück nicht nur
jetzt bei straftaten sondern generell
ein generell gesellschaftlicher und
jetzt nur verurteilen und womöglich eine
politik im moment ist natürlich auch so
wenn jemand dann verteilt wird und
gerechte das entscheiden dann muss das
natürlich auch akzeptiert werden also
dieses herum barmen bei dem uli hoeneß
zum beispiel ist ja damals vorteil wegen
steuerhinterziehung
also diese tränen geschichten sozusagen
dafür jeder präsident des vereins werden
wenn ich 30 millionen satzung habe das
wünsche ich will bei jugendlichen
straftätern das ist sowas gibt ihn also
gibt auch die andere seite aber ist
verselbstständigt sich und worauf ich
noch hinweisen möchte ist was die
intervention sozusagen die
journalistische die kann meines
erachtens auch entscheidungen
beeinflussen also wenn jetzt jemand der
bekannt ist dem vorwurf der
kinderpornografie was eben besonders
stark verurteilt wird auch also
gesellschaftlich zu recht aber
gleichwohl muss man natürlich den die
den maßstab waren und da ist es schon
mal eine feste überzeugung dass
derjenige dann direkt mann aus schlag
bekommt oder zum teil das ist ein
anderes beispiel die die raser mörder
ganz lange jahrzehnte war das
fahrlässige tötung dann hat unter
anderem die bild zeitung darüber raser
mörder bezeichnet und so weiter ich will
nicht sagen dass das ihr zu sagen das
gericht insoweit beeinflusst hat zu
sagen okay das ist jetzt mord aber es
spielt mit rein denn wo kommt das denn
her plötzlich so ein wechsel und da ist
es eben ganz weil wir reden hier von
existenzen existenzen von menschen in
zweifel ich habe das auch schon
tatsächlich persönlich erlebt dass
jemand er beschuldigt worden ist auch ja
medial nicht bekannt eine bekannte
person medial da sehr verfolgt wurde
sage ich mal und das ganze endete sehr
tragisch und diese verantwortung haben
journalisten und journalistinnen schon
das gericht anders das haben sie ja
zurecht gesandt amerika werden die
gerichtsprozesse partie gestreamt haben
wir nicht die kamera ist aus sobald der
prozess
und dann können journalisten drin sitzen
und darüber schreiben das ist schon auch
deutlich besser aber auch da kann man
natürlich so eine art hexenjagd
veranstalten und das sollten wir doch
vermeiden zum schutze der angeklagten
zum schutze der mutmaßlichen opfers
problem ist nur dass die medien
natürlich ein größeres interesse haben
wenn es sich in irgendeiner form
unbekannte um nicht zu sagen prominente
vermeintliche täter handelt wären sie um
nobody's die das brutalste machen was
geht wie jetzt im fall wermelskirchen
mit diesen kinderpornografischen
geschichten da gehst du auf den fall ein
soweit ich den jetzt verfolgt habe in
allen zeitungen sehr cool und sachlich
und unter zitierung der polizei und da
merkst du auch die betroffenheit das
selbst ermittler sagen so was ist uns
noch nie untergekommen aber der ton ist
sachlich weil der typ wäre erstmal
wissen sie nicht genau wissen war wäre
das ist aber das ist keiner den man so
schon klar gesteht er hat keine
geschichte werden ist nur krank das ist
auch schon unterschied und wenn es
natürlich im fall in amerika sind nun
wenn wir zwei ganz froh wenn er stürzt
sich doch alles drogen boris tadi wird
wie man alle was an und skoda die ganzen
plagiats-affäre ja auch noch einmal
zugenommen haben sozusagen den letzten
jahren und vor allem immer in
wahlkämpfen ja wenn man dann auch
inzwischen das gefühl das ist dass
gerade dann rauskommt wenn jemand
abgeschossen werden sollen und so weiter
und so fort also ich finde schon auch
jetzt in jüngerer zeit ja das sagen wir
mal corona stichwort ja wer was gesagt
hat wie auch immer dass das was man so
hexenjagd nennen könnte öffentliche
hexenjagd dass das auch im sinne einer
vorverurteilung allgemein also jetzt
jenseits auch diese sexualdelikte die
glaube ich noch mal ganz besonders sind
ganz spezifisch ganz besonders natürlich
auch in die intimsphäre eben eingreifen
aber dass allgemein die vorverurteilung
zugenommen hat also ich würde zum
beispiel aber das stichwort nennen
wikipedia ist ja so eine open source wo
eigentlich jeder über jeden alles
mögliche schreiben kann ja und bis man
das dann wieder rausbekommen wenn es
irgendwie nicht stimmt dann verliert
echt mal zeit ja also das ist ja auch
eine vorverurteilung dass jeder
überleben und ja genau und meinung
schaden kann man nie wieder genau machen
der ist dann da weil man sozusagen
einmal negativ gedeckt wurde und
um wegzugehen von der rein rechtlichen
frage wir sagen ja auch dazu
alles so zu skandalisieren dass die
ganze öffentlichkeit bestürzt ist also
tief kann sagen das ist ein fettnäpfchen
die frau lambrecht wieder getreten ist
mit diesem helikopter flog aber dass das
jetzt ein großer skandal ist obwohl es
rechtlich sogar erlaubt ist was er
gemacht hat das finde ich bei uns
überzogen was kann der werden gemacht
der
akku war es umgekehrt sagen die großen
skandale wo wirklich steuergelder
verbraten werden ja also an die chancen
und versinkt oder wirecard und und las
auch jetzt wirklich richtigen sachen ja
nix geschäfte und so weiter die keiner
mehr versteht dem handelsblatt gemacht
werden wo im prinzip republik vermögen
muss man sozusagen wirklich veruntreut
in großem stil da regt sich keiner auf
aber der lebenslauf von anna-lena oder
irgendwie so eine halbe universität
studiert wurde das war natürlich ein
großer skandal kommt ihr das glaube ich
jetzt zugute weil die leute sie
unterschätzt haben es kann auch anders
umgehen bei dem kunden berg ist der kann
über das wasser gehen
aber im gegensatz zu weil
die leute haben den zum kaiser der
plagiats geschichten habe ich immer
gesagt guttenberg war ein skandal dass
in echt weil er glaube ich nichts
eigenes geschrieben oder jedenfalls 80
prozent war
ich war auch noch betroffenen hält bei
den anderen bin ich schon sehr
zurückhaltend also wasser waren bei
gefahr
mein gott ist das so schlimm wenn man so
was vergisst wenn der rest aber
vernünftig ist ist dass das was uns in
der gesellschaft sieht sein denn so
vereinfachung glaube ich auch wirecard
und so weiter das ist super kompliziert
verstehen vielen ländern oder auch
dieser helikopter flug aus können
diese empörung kultur
ist glaube ich das problem und die
zerstört wirklich jetzt gerade noch mal
auf ihr thema zurückzukommen die
zerstört eben ganze biografien